you are now recording okay
uh it's 932 as chair of the division
three of the house finance committee i
find that due to the state of emergency
declared
by the governor as a result of covet 19
pandemic in
accordance with the governor's emergency
order 12 pursuant to executive order
2020-04
has extended this public body is
authorized to meet electronically
please note that there is no physical
location to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
which was authorized pursuant to the
governor's emergency order
however in accordance with the emergency
order i'm confirming that we are
providing public access to the meeting
by telephone with additional access
possibilities by video or other
electronic means
we are using the zoom video webinar for
this remote meeting all members of the
committee
and the staff of state agencies with
agenda items have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through this platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously watching or listen to
the meeting on zoom
or phone during the following the
directions and links provided in the
house calendar
starting in house calendar eight running
through the current version they're all
on the
gen court website um the public
is a uh has been provided notice
of uh information for accessing the
meeting
via telephone those are also in the
house calendar
we are providing a mechanism for the
public to
alert us if they have problems with that
access they'll
email us at lba underscore f i s
c a l at l e g dot state dot
nh dot u s if we do get emailed or
otherwise find out we have a problem
with the public
participating or watching
we will adjourn and reschedule note that
um all the votes that we take in this
meeting shall be done by roll call
we can start by taking a roll call
attendance
each member please stay where you are
and if there's anyone around you
so we comply with the right to know law
mr clerk are you ready to take a role
i am
earth present home alone in my home
office
representative weiler i'm here in
kingston alone in this room there's
others in the house
representative i'm home and guilford my
wife is
in and out of the in and out of the
house
representative i'm at my home in concord
and i'm alone representative nordgren
i'm here in my dining room in hanover
and i'm alone
representative rogers i'm here i'm in
concord i'm with my dog romeo
and otherwise alone representative
edwards i'm in my home office in
auburn there are others in the house but
my door is shut
all projects thank you so much
so uh representative wallner let's start
with you do you have a question ma'am
i do i was wondering if i could ask um
representative wyler
sort of his plan for um
when we will meet as a full finance
committee
and then also what he thinks what date
he thinks he might be doing the
budget briefing
i have uh set the 26th
for us to exec as a full committee on
the bills that we have before
us and i think that's going in the
calendar
and we want to make sure we have all the
reports and all the divisions finished
and then
i have to get together with the
speaker and the clerk to schedule the
presentation to the
to the house on the budget i don't know
whether they've got me scheduled
in those that three-day session or
whether i should try to do it the week
before
like on the 30th or or the 31st so
i've got to get together with them and
see what what they want to do because
you know we've got to have a a big space
so i don't know
it's complicated to go and book that and
all that stuff so
i'm going to find out probably today
whether there's
something set up for us on that
three-day
deal okay great
thank you thank you for that question
because
that that stirs in my mind the idea that
we're not scheduled to vote uh out
of uh division three house bill 254
or 600 until monday if we did that on
monday
it would not hit the calendar
so that it was noticed for the 26th
is that a is that a problem do i do we
need to vote on
on 254 sooner so it can be in the
calendar
no i'll just just make the assumption
and have it in the calendar for the 26th
we'll have all the bills that before all
the divisions and we'll have them all
for the 26th
we can continue to plan on voting it out
of division three on monday without it
being a problem
yes
okay so um
today's work uh
yes ma'am i represent an order all right
thank you very much good morning
um could represent wilder please
clarify something he said he said
we're gonna need a big space
for the informational session on the
budget i was unsure what he meant by
that
well if we're going to have
we don't have we don't have a method to
do 400 people on a zoom session
so i assume i'll get together with the
clerk and the speaker and see if
there's any other plan but i assume that
we'll have
maybe an hour or so uh in those three
days
if we want to do it before the house and
have session
and hence questions and so on but uh
i haven't got into that discussion yet
so
i'm still confused but that's okay
no i just what i meant by the big space
was if we want to have it before all the
members of the house
represent no i
just my husband just came in the room
just so you'll know um
so okay i'm trying to understand i
thought that we were having
the budget on the floor of the house
which will be at the sports arena
on the seventh which is the first of the
three days
and i thought that i thought we as i
remember the briefing needs to be a
couple of days before so are you
thinking we will have
the briefing
at an on-site location
i don't know how else we can do it and
still do it before everybody in the
house
because of the because of the setup we
haven't been we haven't been able to
work out a
400 member zoom at this point
so well i don't know whether we have to
have the briefing before that or whether
it's going to be or it's going to be
part of that because we
we could do it on the first day and then
vote on the third day or whatever
but i haven't had a chance to sit down
with the speaker and this and the clerk
and and work that out
every time i went to the meeting i got a
meeting here so
okay thank you
okay i'm i'm not seeing any other
questions so
um let's uh let's get uh ourselves
oriented to the day
um i've i've emailed this and i think
we've uh
we've shared this in other ways that
we're going to hit
hb2 sections 26 30
31 33 38 and we're going to finish up
section 39 uh representative walner will
uh will
will take us to conclusion there i'd
like to
discuss those and hopefully vote on
those and then we'll have
a time i think to talk about um
hb1 and hb2 so so that's
that's kind of the game plan and uh
mr ripple if you would bring up section
of house bill 2 please oh representative
rogers yes ma'am
um you said yesterday that we were going
to start out by having representative
earth give us a
tutorial on how to find things and how
to use oh
yeah i did and i didn't write it on my
note
so so so you're right um
uh let's uh gosh it just it does feel to
me like just
uh like we we've already moved past it
but
representative irf can you can you give
us like three minutes
on how you how you built your
spreadsheet
and uh i think mr ripple may need to
give you
uh authority to share your document
chairman edwards before we get into the
ripple mr ripple is not on the call
right now he's trying to get back on
um i can't share any documents so if you
need to just let me know
can you delegate to representative erf
to share
these if they did it chairman you're
currently
listed as the host so it uh it's within
your authority to do it
oh well let's see how i do that then
um i look go to participants i go
to earth i click on
earth before you do that can i just ask
either
sharon or i'm sorry representative
norgan or representative
um any of the people that want the
tutorial what it is they're looking for
in a tutorial is that how to search the
document is it
what is it you want to know yeah
last night i was looking for something
um i was looking for the sununu center
on the list
and you can't really find stuff on the
list
i mean it's really difficult so that i
think we just need a clarification of
how do we even find
a department on your list it seems
difficult anyway that's whatever that
maybe i'm just confused
no no you're not going to hear me let me
let me speak you don't need to share any
screens
i understand that okay um
you're right you can't i mean i assume
people be looking at this on a computer
screen
and they would be searching for the
words because it is a pdf document and
you can search for it
but let me say this um i don't think you
have to worry about it
um as we discussed uh yesterday
this is not the budget so i don't think
we're going to be talking any more about
that document and
i'm sure the channel will correct me if
i'm wrong but assuming we're
not referring to it any further are
there any
other issues with that document
um i guess my problem was the same is
that i'm trying to find things on there
because i didn't
i as i understood we were adding to this
baseline is how you wanted to do the
budget and i
was trying to find places and i couldn't
find things i tried to figure out
what order it was in and i actually did
try to use it on the computer
and do a find or search but i couldn't
figure out where you put things
and what words you use to um i i
actually on on a few different places i
tried up to 10 different ways to search
it
and i still couldn't find things okay
fair enough but i know that these are
not my words
this is the dhhs document this is not
something i made up
so what i search for when i'm searching
it is the four digit account numbers
if i happen to know the actual name it
will work but you have to know the
actual name of course not just some
something that's close so i tend to use
account numbers
but i did not make up the ordering or
the wording that's a straight that's
especially just straight out of dhhs so
you all work from the
big pdf document that you that we get
and we also at the same time got the
spreadsheet and that's what i was
working from so that's exactly what that
document is
that that i sent out
so we have to go if we search
we put in the search issue as the
account number
so for instance in in your case if
you're comfortable which i think
please share the document and do a live
example
please yes i understand that but you had
me doing a bunch of other things
right now buddy and i just don't have
that right at my fingertips if you give
me something i don't know
we it got overlooked yesterday i asked
people to help me figure out
what we were going to do today and
tomorrow
and i and all of us forgot that we were
going to do this tutorial
so mr chairman
wait a second so representative rogers
has properly reminded us
that we did commit to doing the tutorial
and and it's and it's my fault for not
putting it on the thursday agenda and
reminding everyone
so i'm sorry but representative
rogers is correct now what were you
saying representative rogers
um are we not going to president earth
said we're not going to use this anymore
is that
the fact or are we i think we've
it's largely been used i think it's
largely been used it served its purpose
to be a baseline
we went through several major accounts
yesterday to figure out
you know the difference between the fy21
baseline
and what the governor's budget would
uh do in terms of using the funds
available
to us from the ways and means estimate
so
so to the extent that i think uh we
got to mmis
and we were largely out of resources at
that point
i don't really see us needing the earth
working document at this point
i think it served its purpose which is
kind of why i didn't think it was
worth sharing with the public because it
was such a transitory working document
representative wallner you had your hand
up and you took you've taken it down
so i guess mr mr chair i
so if we're not going to use that
document how are we proceeding
there it is there it is okay
so so can you show us how you would
search
like so for ex example search on
um the medicaid code that we used what
was it something like
7048 or something
so up in the upper right hand corner in
the search bar
you typed in seven nine eight four
start typing 7948 7948
and and there he found medicaid
management so
so if you search on the activity codes
that have been used by the department
and by the governor
you can find the account lines
in representative verse document
now it would also work i think if if he
were to type in
um something like uh admin
on aging can you type words in
admin
on adm there it is
yeah there it is so so you can use
either the account code or the names
of the state he didn't invent any of
that
so that that's how you do a search in a
pdf
are there any questions on searching on
the pdf
i i think for the most part we're kind
of this document has served its useful
life
because it was used yesterday
extensively for us to figure out
how much how many dollars we had
to invest in various parts of the budget
based on
an fy21 baseline so
so thank you representative irv
i'm not seeing any questions on on
representative verse document at this
point
okay can we go and thank you
representative rogers for
for reminding me that i did commit to
that tutorial
thank you representative wallner
so if we're not using representative
erf's document any longer
how are we how are we proceeding
on the behalf of one we are proceeding
with the discussions that have been
scheduled for
uh thursday and for friday um uh
we we will we will be building uh
a house bill one amendment
uh and uh we will discuss the amendment
on monday and maybe vote on it on monday
and if we don't vote it on it on monday
we'll vote on it on tuesday
but that the discussion that we've had
will be reflected in the house bill one
amendment
that we'll bring in for discussion and
voting
thank you sure good question
um and hopefully i said that in the
email i sent earlier
that voting on it on monday is is an
aspirational goal
um all right so house or
hb2 section 26.
can we pull up that mr ripple and show
it
sure
foreign
okay can everyone see it on their screen
or
seen it see it at home
and i can bring up the statute that this
references since it may not be too
obvious
from the language here what it's doing
representative weiler when we discussed
this initially
said that he would recommend that we
just simply remove this section
is that still the case representative
weiler i think that's what we heard from
ms rounds and some other people in hhs
they said even if we remove this it
still
would have the same effect what's what's
in law present
so did you want me to bring karen over
she's still in the audience as of now
sure
good morning hi hello
um i i think that uh
there might be some confusion between
this section and another section this is
a section that the department
would kindly request to keep in
this allows us to transfer funds
from personnel class lines to elsewhere
and the best example i can give was was
one that
representative earth got to see this
morning
um which is we budget moe for lots of
things
in personnel lines and so if a person of
a position
is not filled we still need to meet that
moe so we need to move those funds out
of the
personnel line sometimes to contract
lines to make sure that we meet the moe
so it is a really important
provision to be able to manage the
department financially
um and also the other thing i would say
about it is it also deport
it forces hhs to
manage their own budget so when without
this language
hhs would be put into the pool
with all other agencies uh
regarding personnel so if a personnel
line is overspent
you go to the pool to bring money in but
you can't use that pool for anything
else
so it it sort of incrementer mingles us
with everyone else and
i think it's important that dhhs manage
their own budget
and and not be reliant on other agencies
lapses
so representative
my note did say that you suggested
removal and then we i added a note that
the department will address it
and i i think ms brown's just addressed
it
are you satisfied or do you have other
questions
sir well i think i was confused with a
different section
i got confused if you want i would make
a motion to accept this
just one other thing i'm sorry go ahead
um the other thing i would add is the
department put in the request for this
transfer authority to end on 6 30 at the
end of the biennium
um which has been traditionally what's
been happening it's been a biennium
thing so we would request that it went
until the end of the biennium the
governor's office did change it
to be january um and my understanding it
is that they
wanted us to see what would happen
if we only had it if we didn't have it
i'm very nervous to see what happens if
we don't have it
so that that would be my request
okay so let's look again at section
26 if we could miss ripple
a comment uh yes sir
before we head this in there would be
several agencies that would
ask to have more people added and so on
and
tell us why they had to add them and add
people to their budget
and then when they ran short of money
they would transfer money out of those
lines that they knew they were going to
keep empty anyway
and spend it on other things and we
so we wanted to keep all the other
departments strictly
to personnel money goes into personal
alliance because
what happens is at the end of the year
das goes in and because some of the
departments didn't have enough money put
in to cover all the
benefit lines especially in the
insurance
that they would take the uh ones that
had a higher
higher income people and they would they
would have a higher input
and they would level them out with the
lower income people that didn't have as
much
contribution toward the insurance so das
wanted them all to all the personnel
lines to stay
as personnel lines for that reason so we
put that in
but um several years ago we decided that
hhs needed more flexibility and i i
supported it i think we all did been
around a while and we put this in
but it's it's kind of temporary because
you know we might want them to go back
if the das comes in with the same
problem we might
want to have everybody keep all the
personnel
money and personnel lines thank you
so i i my interpretation is that this
this provides dhhs additional
flexibility
and if they were to operate in a
constrained budget environment
that that flexibility might be
really important to helping them meet
needs
so is that the case ms rounds in a
constrained budget environment this
becomes more important
yes exactly exactly and and i think i've
talked before like we we never know what
crisis is coming right we didn't see the
opioid crisis all of these things things
that happen within a biennium and we
need to move funds from one area to
another
to address the crisis
so then if if we're predisposed to
accepting this language
um i think we just should uh
the committee members should comment on
whether we should go with the governor's
expiration date of january 1 23
or the traditional end of the biennium
june
30 of 23. are there any thoughts on that
subject
representative wallner
well i would think that the end of the
biennium would make
more sense i mean we would just
discontinue it
in six months before the end of the uh
before the end of the year into the
biennium doesn't seem
like a good plan but i mean
that's just my thoughts yeah do we have
anyone from the governor's office that
might
explain to us the reasoning for
kind of an unusual end date
do you see like lisa english or matlow
i don't see either
so i'm going to tap dance and i'm going
to say that
i'm betting they did that because
they thought that if you get if you let
that
flexibility go all the way to the end of
the fiscal year
you start to motivate uh the use it or
lose it mentality of a lot of budget
people
that say let's figure out how we can
obligate or spend this money
and that tends that use it or lose it
attitude is often wasteful
and so maybe they thought let's let's go
ahead and allow the
the flexibility but let's end the
flexibility so that we don't create
a end of the year panic buying
that would be my theory for why they
picked that date
um why don't we defer this and see if we
could
invite somebody from the governor's
office to just
restate why they wanted it six months
early
uh who can who can reach out to either
of those two
i can send an email right now
all right so we'll come back to that and
uh for
those of you who have your hb2 up
you can go to section 30.
this is the parental reimbursement
this is another one liz rounds where i
think we said that the department should
come talk again about this
yes kevin could you bring meredith over
sure
so i can give you like the 300 000 foot
view and i i don't think that's gonna be
helpful
so she can give you a better view
they're enough are you there
should be in no
hi i'm here can you hear me
yes welcome back
good morning can we also bring in
francesca hennessey
she's coming in now okay
great thank you francesca hennessey is
our administrator for fraud waste and
abuse
hello and worst here she is this is
franchise
specifically go ahead francesca sorry
hi good morning um thank you for letting
us
speak today on this bill i wanted to go
over a little bit of the history
last year um in house bill
1162 the parental reimbursement
obligation
by bipartisan legislation was actually
um taken away there is no longer a
parental reimbursement
obligation and again that happened last
year
um fiscal year 2020 by bipartisan
legislation
the legislation we are proposing today
that you are looking at simply moves the
effective date
back to june of 2020 or
really july 1st 2020 it was supposed to
be effective on january 1st
2021. so
that's section 30. section 31
let's stop let's hold up there sure
so um this is this would be retroactive
so what i assume
okay so what i think this parental
reimbursement was
as i recall was that we could go back
and try to do debt collection from
parents
to help recover some of the costs
associated with the child
services that we provided and that our
debt collection experience on this was
such that
we found that the cost of collection
greatly exceeded
the cost of or the amount that we were
able to obtain
so we were running a losing business
proposition
and and and so i'm guessing that you
guys just
halted it when you could in july 1
2020 and by passing this we're going
back
and giving you guys permission to have
stopped early
yes that is a good summary correct
just to yes by one point though we
it wasn't a it was a a one to one
we weren't bringing in any money we
weren't losing money but we weren't
bringing in any money it cost as much to
run the program as what we were getting
back
okay representative weiler
uh thank you mr chairman i can remember
going way back that if a child was in
the dcyf detention center
and at the time was like a hundred
thousand a year if the child was there a
year
or even six months there was a huge debt
of 50 or 100 000
and you know they would look at the
parents financial of
uh ability and get it
maybe come up with a payment of two or
three hundred dollars a month
and so it was like having another
mortgage so
we did that for a while and then there
were so many complaints
they knocked it down to okay you pay so
much a month
while the child is in the facility and
after that
the payments stop but i wonder if
maybe we overlook the fact that some
parents might have been carrying
what amounted to a second mortgage for
20 or 30 years so
does this relieve those parents that
might have been paying for for years and
years or
did we stop that already no that's a
good question
and that's what the section 31 would
allow us to do
it it would allow us to stop to motion
the court to stop those enforcement
orders so all those orders that are
already in place
so what the legislation did was it then
department you no longer have to
establish orders
as of this date and so section 30 is
asking
can we stop establishing order stop the
program as of
july 1st 2020 instead of january
1 2021 section 31
does allow us as you said to go back all
these we have
over a thousand orders so it would allow
us to petition the court and save this
unit no longer exists can we
stop um this collection and i have a
couple of reasons for that when you're
ready
uh go ahead you're on a roll thank you
um again once this position went away we
had about
six uh financial agents in
this unit they all left so this unit is
now
the collections part of it is being um
handled by our administrative support
staff so we're really not
doing the active enforcement that we
were doing
we are simply collecting checks that
come in
the problem with that is it leads to
some
inequity right so if we're not enforcing
orders of the people who
don't want to pay and we're just
collecting um there's a certain number
of people who aren't paying there's a
certain number of people
um who are and it uh
when running the numbers i looked
quickly last night about a third of our
cases are in delinquency
meaning those parents just aren't paying
and we don't have the staff right now to
bring them back to court to enforce
these orders
i'm not even sure that the um
uh you know the the reasoning behind it
is even there if we brought
this to the court if the court would say
um
hey department the legislator changed
their minds they don't even want you
doing this program anymore why are you
asking me to enforce this so there's
that as well
are there any questions on sections 31
or 30.
okay uh there's a question uh
representative weiler
no i i think there ought to be some way
we can tell parents
you know you didn't you didn't raise
this child responsibly
and this this was a way to get their
attention but
some of the irresponsible children had
irresponsible parents so
i don't notice we changed anything thank
you
all right uh well uh well thank you for
for for coming in uh francesca i
appreciate it
i don't know i don't know if you have
other things to talk about here we're
we're gonna go to section 33 now for a
discussion
and my note here says the governor's
office wanted
replacement language and that was
completed over the weekend
so i think what we're seeing on the
screen is the original
hb2 language is is was the
did we receive replacement language to
this that you know of mr ripple
um i don't you know i don't think so but
karen correct me if i'm wrong maybe you
sent me something that i didn't
notice i did but i probably sent you
about 150 emails in the past so um
yes i did uh draft language i had it
approved by the governor's office and
sent it over all right i'll find that
and send out
well go ahead and take a moment
and see if between the two of you you
can find a way to get it on the screen
and we'll just take a look at it
and and then if anyone from the
governor's office has joined us since we
uh asked them to um please raise your
hand so we can
notice
well i see matt uh is there so uh one
once once we look at 33
we'll come back
okay mr ripple you keep keep doing that
you don't have to change your screen for
us
to keep working on that and if mr malou
could be
allowed to speak i can ask him a
question
yep and i'll bring him in and just stay
focused on
on finding the updated 33.
so so mr mellow and i'm still not saying
your last name
correctly i have no french in me
whatsoever i'm sorry
uh matt uh
we were talking about uh
house bill 30
house bill 26
house bill 2 section 26
and this is one uh i don't know if you
know it offhand
but it gave the dhhs some flexibility in
moving monies around from personnel
lines to other lines
and that typically we would put an
expiration date on that
of the end of the biennium and we have
word that the governor's office wanted
to go with the january 1
2023 date for that
expiration of authority do you recall
that can you
explain to us what your reasoning was
yes representative
and thank you for the question uh this
section
is a prospective repeal that was first
passed in senate bill
580 from 2018.
the legislature during the last budget
process
opted to extend that prospective repeal
for another biennium
what hb2 does it extends it once again
for 18 months if
the legislature no longer wants to
repeal
this transfer authority i would argue
that
we should eliminate the prospective
repeal entirely
if that's the prerogative but the
governor's office our position was that
it would take effect
within this biennium rather than
continuing to
kick that date two years out at a time
so so thank you for that background
while you were
um while we were asking for you to come
in
one of the observations we made and i i
want to see if you share this thought
is that in a period
of constrained budgets
this authority to transfer
gives the dhhs leadership
some flexibility that could help them
navigate through
budget constraints that is correct
uh representative edwards and i can't
speak to
why this bill was brought forward in
but it did it did become law
right so clearly at one point this
legislature believed that this transfer
authority should sunset
and then again the legislature
subsequently delayed that by two years
and then
uh we've even proposed to delay it
another 18 months
you're absolutely right that the
department does utilize this unique
transfer authority
to move money between class lines in a
way that other agencies aren't able to
and during a constrained budget session
like the one we're in
that may be worthwhile what i would
argue is if the legislature's
prerogative is to remove this
prospective repeal
right to delay this prospective repeal
yet again
for a whole biennium it probably
warrants a conversation as to whether or
not
this provision of law should remain on
the books if it does not appear that it
will ever actually
take effect okay will you
uh take a question from representative
wallner be happy to
representative thank you chairman and
thank you matt for being here
um i wondered why you picked 18 months
instead of the full biennium
so our and this was something of debate
right we wanted to make sure the
department did have
a glide path to adopt to
losing this transfer authority you could
argue that it should be
the start of any given fiscal year
our thinking was that by picking january
1st
if it did become apparent that this was
a serious issue for the department to
manage through
by not having this transfer authority
our thinking was that the legislature
would be in session at that point
and could take quick action to reverse
that repeal
if necessary if you do it on july 1
the legislature is not in session in
most years and let's hope we're not in
session come july 1 this year either
there's less of a window of opportunity
to rectify the issue
if it becomes operationally difficult
for the department so that was our
thinking in picking january 1st
and again the intention of putting this
language into hb2 was that
if this law is going to continue to
exist on the books it should take effect
at some point
rather than just kicking it out a whole
biennium you know year after year if you
will
you have a follow-up
okay i just wouldn't we be
in session and doing the budget
during that period of january to
to june and at that point evaluate
whether or not we wanted to include it
in the next budget
the legislature would be until june
and as part of that right as you're
going through the budget for the next
two years
you're experiencing in real time whether
or not this is actually a substantial
issue
or not right obviously the legislature
could
reverse this through a bill that is not
hb2
that this transfer
i lost you yeah you're having some audio
issues
yeah i think i think he's answering my
question thank
you thank you matt thank you for being
here okay
are there any other questions for matt
from the governor's office
uh i i think your hands still up but you
don't have a follow-up representative
no i'm i'm all right
so uh uh and mr chairman just one last
thing if i may
yes sir is that again if the legislature
does want to extend this for the full
biennium that's certainly within your
prerogative
what i would say is maybe we eliminate
the prospective repeal
and i know karen at hhs has articulated
why this is important to the department
uh and i think just decide which
direction we went ahead and
just decided to you know row in the same
direction at that point
okay i i'm gonna listen to the committee
members that have been around
finance longer than i have i i happen to
be predisposed to accepting the
governor's recommendation on this but
i'm i'm open to
a discussion there so um
thank you uh
so mr ripple were you able to find the
new language and maybe with matt here
since we were saying that the governor's
office looked at this language and
improved replacement language he could
participate in that as well
okay karen can you explain uh
what you remember about why we thought
the the existing language in hb2 needed
this amendment and what this amendment
is trying to do
sure so the existing language and hb2
has a lot of unintended consequences
um going back to tanf
and the general funds being budgeted for
the moe all across the department if it
if it's not um spent then we need to
move it and then we would replace it
with a federal fund and the way that
that language was written
we would then have to lapse the general
fund and we wouldn't have it available
for moe because
technically the federal funds supplanted
it and that's just a
one very small example um so when i
uh talked to the governor's office about
it they understood
my concerns and were willing to uh let
me propose
language that still uh met
what they were trying to obtain which
was
um just more transparency around when we
uh may be accepting an additional
federal dollar that may offset
a general fund dollar um and then what
would happen with those general fund
dollars so
that's what this language does it puts
in a reporting requirement that when we
are doing a transfer or an exception
expend with fiscal committee
that uh we are reporting about
supplanted general fund dollars
um and reporting on how much of that is
anticipated to lapse versus
used for other purposes
all right so do we see
a a longer term opportunity to put any
of this in an
rsa or is this something that's going to
live forever in an hb2
so i mean certainly my preference where
this is the first time
we we've done this would be to see how
it goes because i don't
we haven't exactly figured out how we're
going to report on it
and what questions might come up so my
suggestion would be one biennium with it
as it is let's see
how the reporting goes what questions
fiscal committee might have
and then refine it if we need to
represent while or sir
i've forgotten which section this
replaces
33 thank you
33's got just a short five lines
20 of it's a title
so uh matt while you're on with us
do you do you have any uh
interest in revising or extending this
round's remarks
i would say that our office did consult
with uh karen
on this we do agree section 33 of hb2 as
drafted is problematic
and we would support revising it to be
the language that you see here on the
screen
were there any other questions from the
committee members
um and let's just check real quick the
audience uh the the just to see if there
are any hands up i i doubt if there
would be but let's double check
uh are there any i don't see any hands
up so
uh so i would entertain a motion at this
point to accept the draft language as
shown on the screen
as replacement language for section 33
of hp2
in the zero second and then there's a
second uh moved by
irf seconded by wyler
is there any discussion on the motion
not seeing any uh would the clerk take a
roll
you're muted okay on the
question to amend section 33
as shown on house bill 2
is to accept the amendment
representative earth
yes representative weiler votes yes
representative bean yes
representative walder yes
representative nordgren yes
representative rogers yes representative
edwards yes mr chairman the vote is 7-0
to amend
very good thank you um
all right so where are we we are
ready to take a look at section 38.
yep so let me bring that up um while i'm
doing that just so you know i am going
to have ols draft
that language that you just just
accepted in the form of a formal
amendment with an amendment number and
everything so once that
i'll bring it in uh bring it in for the
committee to look at
right i i think
technically what you just told me is we
should have done it the other way i
should ask you to make get ols to make
that amendment and then we'd vote on a
formal amendment
well yes but i didn't tell you that in
time so oh you've told me before i just
uh
i need to make the same mistake two or
three times before i remember so
not your fault thank you sure
so my note on 38
said this seems like a committee bill or
should be under a current program
already
why is this a section hb2 section
the the governor's office may be
thinking this is a one-time
deal and maybe it was realized too late
to put into hb1 and so my question was
do we drop it from hb2 or do we accept
it
so
so this was a proposal that i think
allowed care coordination out in the
community
by funding for an additional period of
time
the transmission of what is called an
eight
adt transaction or event
out to receiving information systems
around the state
so that they would know if there was a
discharge
and they would know that a patient was
re-entering
or transferring into their community
and the sum needed to continue those adt
transactions was two hundred thousand
dollars
and it didn't find and this is 200 000
that did not
find its way into hb1
so um so is that an is that a accurate
summation ms rounds
that is my understanding yes
so this is something that we could move
into hb1
yeah i i because the program exists
right you're already doing the adt
transactions so this is just a
funding of an ongoing operation
right yes
so that we could we could drop it and
and care and need to worry about it is
something that's already
potentially funded or needs additional
funds for hb1
correct the 200 000 would need to be in
hv1 it would be
in the bureau of information services
budget and class 37
i believe so you'll help us find that
line item
later again please when i'm able to look
at a spreadsheet maybe
but um all right so
uh is there any are there questions from
the committee
on this i mean i think the momentum on
this is that we want to delete this from
hb2
because this is a this is an operational
item this program's already in operation
and this is just funds that are
can need to be allocated internally to
this
uh function
i'm not seeing any questions um uh dave
wetters is he coming in today or is that
tomorrow
so that's tomorrow um they so he wants
to bring
um the commissioner for doit with him as
well and so they're uh
available between 10 and 12 tomorrow and
i'm not sure exactly what the plan is
for tomorrow i know there's also a
fiscal committee meeting
um so i don't know if we could do it
closer to 10
um
i was just thinking in my head whether
we should go ahead and
take a vote on this now right or wait
for
his input but i it seems pretty
straightforward to me
um i i would entertain a motion to
uh delete section 38 from hb 2.
some of this ripple mr ripple wants to
mr
wants to change their name i'm sorry
before you continue with that i
i would suggest that deleting anything
as well as changing anything would also
require an ols amendment because
in both cases you're amending the bill
okay so um do you want to
take an action then to to draft an
amendment to delete section 38 please
and then we can vote on it amendments
ready
yes representative do you have a
question
yes i do so is the uh proposal here to
delete it from house bill 2 and we will
add it in house bill 1.
that it will be cover okay so the first
half of that is
is literally correct and i agree with it
it
would be this is an operational expense
of an ongoing existing
program and and should be funded within
hb1 when they built hb1
apparently they overlooked the funding
requirements for this
and so so separately they are asking
us to put 200 000 into a line item
in hb1 to support this ongoing program
so it's not in the governor's proposal
it's not in
i mean you could argue that it's in the
fy21 base because
uh it is an ongoing program
but but it does appear to be a new
demand
for resources that is not currently
reflected
in the governor's budget proposal
does that answer your question do you
have a follow-up
well i guess i yes i do i i guess i
don't quite understand i went
so if we take it out of here and we
don't
do an amendment to house bill one that
adds it in
then they've lost it well are they
we just have talked about giving them an
authority to reprogram pretty
generously within line items
so so they would be in a situation
of a budget constraint where they would
need to make priorities and maybe
move some money around to cover this
program that
sounded like this program was pretty
important so maybe it has a high enough
priority to compete well
internally or we could add 200 000 more
well i think to me it feels like
we have to decide do we want to fund
this program or don't we and this is the
sort of the spot if we take it out of
here and we don't put it in one
then the decision was that we didn't
want to fund it
if we want to fund it and we want to put
it where it
approp should be appropriately then we
have to do something in house bill one
an amendment to house bill one to make
sure this money goes over to
house bill one uh one otherwise the
decision now
if we don't do the if we don't do
something in house bill one the decision
is we decided we didn't want to fund
this
particular item well that we didn't want
to
provide dedicated funding we're not
telling them not to fund it either
though
so we're sort of uh would allow an
internal
transfer to cover it based on a
departmental priority but
so submit we're not making any decision
today because as mr ripple correctly
stated
he needs to draft an amendment with ols
and we're not going to take a vote
on what to do with section 38 until we
have an amendment
and then we can discuss this again so
but so ms rounds would you
would you add this topic to mr
watters to come in and tell us about
because
i want to understand that two hundred
thousand is that a hundred thousand a
year
and that just seems like a boatload of
money for
an i.t system that's already set up to
trigger hl7 messages i don't see that
as being in i don't i don't understand
an
incremental cost to an existing it
function
that should cost tens of dollars
not 200 000 so
so i i if he could come back and explain
why it would cost so much to maintain a
hl7 transaction that'd be great
yes i will ask him to also speak to that
representative and i wasn't ignoring you
if you have a question
please ask it
all right so we're gonna we're gonna
defer 38 and we're going
to add conversation from mr rutter's to
give us
more details on on justifying 200
000 for it
i'm ready to move on to
section 39. this is uh the section that
representative wallner
opened up to us on monday i i don't
think uh
anyone has submitted a draft
to uh mr ripple for us to vote on
in this case you did because you did
discuss it the other day and there was
some discussion about removing the
section entirely i did have an amendment
drafted that i just literally just got
from ols
to delete this section so if you were so
inclined you could vote on that
okay it's good to have that flexibility
so
so representative walner uh would you
would you remind us what we said on
monday and what your current thinking is
why i think that what we
talked about what um was your suggestion
really actually of
of taking it out at this time and in
april
some point in april when we have a
little more time
basically having a public information
session where people can come in and
talk to us about this section
so that the house finance committee
will have information to move forward i
mean i think that
my assumption was that we felt like
there was a lot of information we needed
and we our time was getting was getting
short
so um that that was a suggestion you
brought in and i thought it sort of made
sense
and there like i said there were a
number of bills floating around over the
last
three or four years about this and this
has been in the budget before
and actually it's non-lapsing money from
the 20 from the 2021 budget
that was in this line and this does
this particular proposal has
bonding in the operating budget and i
think that
is sort of a decision that
is a serious one for the legislature to
start down that
down that path we've been there before
all right so representative do you have
follow-on questions well i just wanted
to know
one of the bills that i have written is
senate bill 156
kevin can you refresh us on what that
bill does please
senate bill 156 i believe inserted into
the language that was in the trail
bill from two years ago a provision to
prevent the department from contracting
with a for-profit
prison company or run the facility
okay thank you
and i would also second what
representative walner said i think we
have had this discussion already
but we need to remind ourselves that
we're
a little concerned that this isn't going
through the capital budget process in
public works
i think representative rogers also
pointed out that she didn't think it
had been properly or fully coordinated
with the city of concord
and and that that struck me as something
that ought to be done
so um okay
so i i think we should entertain a
motion
to can you show the amendment on the
screen mr ripple
yep let me just bring that up oh there's
representative rogers would you go ahead
and while you're bringing that on the
screen representative rogers do you have
a question
i just wanted to comment you talked
about the city i did in fact talk to the
mayor
and um he said that neither he nor the
city manager had been contacted about
this
and they wanted they would would very
much like to be contacted and talk
have some involvement with the planning
of this and where
what's going on with it so i would hope
that um the department would make sure
that that happens in the future
so if we could send a strong message to
the department
um it doesn't need to necessarily be in
the amendment but i would hope that um
you as the chairman of this division
might help send a
a strong message to the department that
that's something we'd like to see happen
okay well i i think with the department
listening in on the hearing and
and i think hearing us all basically say
the same thing
after this vote they may have a
a big part of the message thank you very
much
there was a meeting scheduled for 316
i'm not sure who it was with the city of
concord but
there was a meeting scheduled i don't
know that it happened but that was
the information that i got karen i would
just ask that somebody contact the mayor
in the city manager's office
as well i don't think they've been
contacted it's been at a lower level
but okay thank you thank you
representative do you have any comments
sir before
before i call for a motion i do not so
i'd entertain a motion to
adopt amendment 2021-089-0
hotel
a second
is there any discussion on this
amendment
that's not seeing any uh
mr clerk would you take a role
representative earth yes representative
weiler votes yes representative bean
yes representative walner
yes representative nordgren
yes representative rogers
yes representative edwards
yes 7-0
all right um very good uh thank you
thank you representative walner for
getting more organized than i did
to to lead us through that conversation
i appreciate it
thank you so so looking ahead at
tomorrow
uh we have some some sections
uh that we're we're going to talk about
in in more detail but
but let's let's sort of uh headline them
um
mr ripple can you can you get us back to
hb2 section 34
please all right and then we're just
going to just
briefly look at 3435 37 41.
okay so there's an amendment coming in
on section 34 reproductive health
facilities
it's going to the amendment's going to
be introduced by representative erica
leon uh i believe
the following i believe everyone's been
sent on the committee has been sent the
amendment
and i believe that this has been posted
on the lba
website and i know that i mentioned
to um kayla montgomery
of planned parenthood that she may want
to uh listen in tomorrow morning
so um so do you have
so so so is it can you confirm
mr ripple that this did get on the lba
website
yes
i'm sorry but could kevin maybe resend
the amendment that she's bringing in
i i don't know where i have it
thanks it's only one of the 400 emails
that you have in there
so i ca i can't keep track either
it's just so much um section
35 uh
what was this about this was oh this is
about the
a m study and having 10 million dollars
i think i've heard from his rounds that
this a
m report has been completed and that
we've been sent a copy
and that this is one of the big things
that i
have been wanting to read or look at but
i personally have not done that
can we confirm that this a
m report is completed and has been
emailed to us
is that is that is that true it has been
emailed to you and it's also posted on
our website
and then uh for anyone who's looked at
it i'm just curious did
is that ten million forty three thousand
dollars
for the biennium is that backed up by
the report for the
people who have looked at the report or
or or is that
an estimate that needs to be refined do
we know
mr uh representative weiler
i don't remember seeing it specifically
in the report but saw it later in
another form a report
was actually four reports and
you know there was a lot of repetition
in all of them but
there were several places where they
showed savings
if the department would would file their
paperwork a little differently
so they could get more federal funds and
so i
i'd like to ask miss rounds who have
maybe
done more thorough adding up of all
those little sections
if those savings if they were
followed would amount to at least 10
million
i uh not
let's be fair to you we're not really
discussing this until
tomorrow i think yeah i think so you got
24 hours to kind of
stick your nose into that yeah let me
let me think about it
let me think about it you understand the
question
i do i do and i it i think it applies to
a couple of different sections of
their report so uh um
let me let me think i representative
weiler asked very about a very specific
finding but i think
all of the findings there's definitely
an roi but i'd rather wait till tomorrow
when i have some of the am
a m folks available um so they can
talk to you about what they found
because they they were really
independent in their review
representative follow-up yeah
and also you have to uh figure out where
the overlap is
because here's two different sections
for the
first time period and then two different
sections for the second time period
you know the recommendations in the in
the first section for the first time
period the same as the
recommendations in the second report on
the same time period i
didn't have the patience to read all the
many pages in the detail and make notes
in the margin but i was just kind of
glancing through and i did see that
there was quite a bit of repetition
in what i saw with two reports in each
of the two time periods thank you
chair if you would like what uh what we
could do starting off tomorrow is have a
m give like a five minute overview of of
what they did
and and their what they reviewed
if that would be helpful you know it
would i
just to talk about tomorrow i i
i i've told uh representative leon
already that section 34 would be
the first up in the batting order and
i'm anticipating that that's probably in
going to take at least an hour right
there so
if you wanted to give the a m people a
heads up
it it's probably about 10 30 at the
earliest before we
we'd come to 35 okay and it'll probably
be a little after that because we have
to
talk to the mmis folks uh around that
time
next because that's the only time
they're available tomorrow oh this is
really good to know
you should tell me when i have to talk
to mmis
yeah it should be right after 34. we
should do
those folks they're going to join at 10
o'clock so they'll be available
as soon as we're done with 34.
we may have to we may have to recess 34
for a little while
i don't know that i want to do that but
if that's
when they're available um
okay so so so
with representative weiler's question
about an
roi being associated with some of this
if it's going if it's going to reduce
and and
produce a net reduction like in fy 23
where yeah yes it's about 5 million
but we're going to get an roi of 3
million you're only asking for two
million of new cash
in fy 23 that's just an example
but if it's if it's that kind of
analysis
then would you make sure that we
understand the net
because we're we're already into the
gray zone where we're
we're looking for money i can absolutely
do that
we want to be sure that those
recommendations can in fact
be accomplished without finding out from
the department that it's impossible to
do
understood so
so that's a that's a preview of coming
attractions on section 35
tomorrow so let's go to section
37 for another preview
now these grants to senior citizens this
feels
like it's an existing program
i i thought we talked uh
in the long-term care supports about a
program that had this function
supporting services to combat struggles
with mental health and social isolation
including but not limited to grants for
safety upgrades and other capital
improvements to improve their facilities
i i is so so i guess tomorrow i would
like
confirmation of whether or not this is a
new program
or an existing program and if it's an
existing program
is this capital money because we're
talking about capital improvements
and if it's operating money in an
existing program why isn't it already in
hb1
did you follow all that yes and i think
this is one that you
as a committee had a question out to the
governor's office on because the
governor's office added this provision
so we really needed them to speak to it
so let's
let's see what my note says why is this
a sec
hb section 852 section the governor's
office may be looking at this as a
one-time thing
i is do we still have matt on
and if we don't can we ask him to come
back at around
uh one o'clock tomorrow to talk to this
section
he's not in the audience but yes i can
ask him to come back tomorrow
section 43.
[Music]
um i'm sorry i didn't hear that which
section
oh section 41. i i said 43 because my
eye is
my left eye is problematic and was
blurring up
so section 43 uh i have meant to follow
up with representative mcquatt mcguire
because she said that historically there
was a reason to not
move the controlled drug prescription
health and safety program into dhhs
and uh and and so
this hb2 could potentially be
problematic because it's circumventing
uh a specific legislative decision from
a year or two ago i think
so so this is my reminder to contact
representative mcguire representative
norgren it looks like you may want to
say something
no
yes go ahead
representative norgren you're on mute
okay i don't i i'm going to assume that
i i misinterpreted your hand motion
there
representative walter
this section
is division one looking at this section
uh also one originally had the section
but they asked
uh division three to take it instead
okay so they don't have it they didn't
make any
they didn't make any comments on it or
give us
any ideas about how they felt about it
i'm not aware of any comments from
division one
okay okay thank you
so i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna try to get
some background from
uh representative mcguire and then rep
ms rounds if you could
uh re-remember the the the argument the
uh institutional argument for moving it
that'd be great
uh representative roller your hand is
still up do you have a follow-up
ma'am i do have a question that i want
to ask you
when we get through um all of these
sections okay representative norgren do
you have a question
yes yeah i think i had a note that the
question was about the office of
professional licensing in division one
so i think that's
the clarification we need
what clarification would you like made
help me understand that
i think the issue was division one deals
with
the office of professional licensing so
the
question that i had written was
should they have seen this and i guess
that's something we're going to
check on thank you i think i think the
answer i just heard from
representative weiler was that that they
they cons that the division one chair
considered this and asked that division
three
take the lead on it and so they've not
come to any determination because
they passed it to us is that is that a
correct assumption
representative yes
um is this a good time to take your
question representative walner
well when i asked a question you can
tell me if it's a good time or not
okay so um i do i have an amendment
um that i would like to bring in it's a
house to
um house bill 2 amendment
what would be the appropriate time for
me to bring that in
so let me just check its status if as
mr ripple had an opportunity to get ols
to pro
to create amendment document for us to
vote on
yes he has does it
address a specific section that's
already in hb2 or does it
add something it really addresses a
section that's in hb
one but i we
we sort of went back and forth mr ripple
and i talked about whether it should be
in house bill one or house bill two
um i think we came down on the side of
house bill 2
but would be open to hearing other
people's ideas about it
it has to do with a line in house bill
1.
i think if you're ready to talk about it
we could talk about it
now but uh let me check with
representative weiler he's got his hand
up
and yeah representative weiler
no i just i thought i lowered it thank
you all right
so i don't want to put you on the spot
though representative walter if you're
not
prepared in this instant to talk about
it we can
maybe come back after lunch
yeah i just the only thing i need to
find is the page
in house bill 1 because we'll have to
use
i think to make to have this make sense
people will need to use both documents
so if you want to do it after lunch i
can have all the um
right lines and everything ready
yes ma'am i want to continue previewing
tomorrow
to talk about sections 24 25 106
110. so if you happen to be able to get
ready to talk about it while we're doing
the previews
you know let me know and and and we'll
offer questions okay good thank you
representative rogers you have your hand
up yes um i have an interest also
in that um i believe i'm not positive
but i believe that um
we had all talked about the sununu
center and possibly amending
something there but um there again i
believe that would go in house bill 2
but i'm not sure where in
um in house bill 1
what what amount we're using as our base
amount
um i was wondering if if
you or representative earth could maybe
explain to me
where or how i can find out what base
amount
for a figure we're using for the sununu
center
if we're using the 12.5 million if we're
using
14.5 if we're using less than that or
whatever
and um if you or anyone else has
has got an amendment or somebody should
be working on amendment or
where we stand on that so i'm kind of
throwing open that question
while we're previewing future actions on
house bill 2.
okay so the most signifi we can do all
of that the the biggest
chunk of what you said that has the
biggest impact i think is
uh the question has anyone done
an hb2 amendment related to the sununu
center
and i can tell you i'm not aware of any
uh if uh representative weiler sir
do you have a comment on that not on the
sununu senate per se i think we should
put something in there to to give
and then shut it down and give them a
year to figure out what they need and
then cut the budget way down
so that they realize we're serious but
we're going back to
uh number 41 we need to alert
hhs because this would be a whole
uh au or uh
appropriating unit you have to have all
the figure out how many people they'd
need and all that sort of thing and it
would be a whole page in hb1
so we've got to give them a heads up if
we're going to
accept this because it basically belongs
in hb1 with a new au
once we accept it thank you
yes sir uh i i'm assuming that it would
be
total over to the overall budget of the
state
it would be budget neutral because it's
an existing program
that would be laterally moved into dhhs
and that
uh changing the finances would be
mechanics that would happen in
background is
my guess represent
rounds do you have a comment about that
or mr ripple
i'm sorry i had to step away for for
okay
okay so so we of course we named you
while you were away
the uh so the i think to
phrase representative weiler's comment
is
if we accept section 41 that would cause
dhhs to need to create new accounting
units and
codes and and it would have to be in hb1
that way
and and my assumption is that this is
an existing program that and all of the
manpower and money
is would be a lateral over
uh later as kind of an administrative
action
that's correct we we brought over the
program exactly
how it was um budgeted by oplc
and it is already uh showing in hb1
in our budget oh it already is so you're
assuming that we're going to approve
this
correct
if it doesn't then if this is removed
then um the budget would get moved back
over to opoc
all right do you have a follow-up
representative
oh you're saying all we have to do is
accept this and it's a done deal
yes
you scroll up uh mr ripple to
section 24.
this is the county cap issue uh i think
representative irf has and i and
others have done a lot of work in this
area
and we talked about it yesterday as we
were trying to do some ad backs
oh i'm going to stop myself
representative rogers you add two parts
to your question
we talked about the the sununu center
for just a moment but didn't finish it
i don't know of any hb2 recommendations
on on uh
on the sununu center and
and and at this point is there anyone in
the committee
that has asked mr ripple to draft
an hb2 for the sununu center or mr
ripple can you just tell us
yes or no if anyone's asked you to draft
such an amendment
no one has asked me to draft that
amendment as of now
okay so so so representative rogers if
you
think that it needs to be amended and
you probably
would not be alone uh you know feel free
to
uh get a group of people together to
figure out what you want to say and
and let's say it uh is that is that okay
all right thanks and then i think you
asked
another question in there about where
could you find the sununu center
in representative earth's document and i
believe if you
uh use that search bar in the upper
right hand corner to look at the
either its account code or the name
sununu
it it should come up for you and and
i am assuming that the that the
the current baseline that would go into
our proposed hb1 amendment at this point
is their fy21 numbers
um so so not adjusted
for fy not not added to in 22 and 23
but just what they were at the end of fy
21.
representative erf are you still there
i'm still here style okay can you
confirm my assumption
that for the sununu center uh
right now we're planning to maintain the
fy21 adjusted
baseline
um
and i guess the answer is yes that's the
plan we we didn't add any back yesterday
we didn't
so using the algorithm
you used the the lower of the governor's
number or fy21 and i assume the fy 21
was lower so that's the number that
we're planning on at this point
yes i'm now going i would apply the
algorithm that is correct but not sure
off top my head which way
it went but that sounds reasonable
representative weiler good comment
question
mr joy wants a meeting later today
and uh he sent me a zoom lim link i
think he has a suggested amendment for
the sununu center
so we'll see what he's got thank you sir
i i asked him for an agenda for that 230
call
and and he just said he wanted to clear
up some confusion
and i i was hoping for something more
specific than that but i guess we'll
find out at 2 30 what what he thinks
we're talking about
because i'm confused maybe maybe i'm the
first one to clear up
so representative rogers i belatedly did
we get to your
uh answers to your question um yes thank
you very much
so uh so section 24.
there's a whole discussion here that
we'll have tomorrow
on the county cap
and uh representative irf uh we talked
about
it a bit yesterday uh i think
we are proposing
to do some add backs to
the this line item and that those add
backs
would keep the rate of increase
at a three percent level we've talked
about it
what it would cost at a two percent
level but
but i i think right now the proposal is
is
somewhere in between there two and three
percent and
with the idea that an hp2 could be
crafted
to um to lock in future
growth at a three percent rate
is is that an accurate summation of your
proposed hb2
representative earth that we would keep
it at the hb2 line would say keep it at
three percent
ongoing uh we can go either way
um i thought we talked about low into
two percent but i am working with kevin
to get that amendment together
so we can send that out so people will
review it and then we can vote on it
because next week
but tomorrow you have time on the agenda
to talk about it in section
when we talk about section 24. i can
certainly speak to the amendment
tomorrow for sure yes i assume you're
kept
ready by them in fact they might already
have it i know kevin
and if ols can produce an amendment we
could maybe vote on it
and that is with ols now okay
all right thank you uh section
25 thank you representative uh
prospective repeal regarding eligibility
of services extended
um we said we needed to talk about this
that's my dog if you can hear that
okay so we talked about this
this repeal i guess yesterday and uh
and uh and we have some more comments on
it but
but bottom line i think this section
25 becomes uh overcome by events
because uh in talking to representative
marsh of hhs
he says that he and he quoted it to me
but i
don't have the the link to it
he quoted me rsa language
that will become effective on july 1
and that rsa language would make section
move and therefore
uh it sounded like we could delete
section 25. so
so could you have oas preparing
8 25 and then we'll talk about it in
more detail tomorrow
sure
i suppose everyone would be okay
deleting this if
in fact it's going into an rsa with a
projected effective date
so um all right so
um footnotes there's
uh i think on the order of 32
footnotes uh and there's a
document that's floating around that
lists them
in sort of uh a grid format uh and shows
where the footnotes are throughout the
hb1
uh and so there's just an issue of
making sure that
uh we've we've we've looked at each
other and we like these footnotes
so so mr ripple would you remind me if
those that footnote document you sent
that to all the
members right i believe i did
yes is that also listed
as its own document on the lba website
or would that have been considered
redundant since the footnotes are in hb1
i'm not sure if we have that one on the
website or not let me take a look
it is it is okay
so if you guys want to prepare yourself
for that
uh you could look at the footnotes and
that document
and figure out if you want to accept the
footnotes or if you have
a change you want to make i i think this
morning i asked mr ripple
to get mr hoffman to create
a short list for us and i would describe
the shortlist
of being assuming fy 19
as the baseline what footnotes got added
in the current budget or and or
are proposed for the for the governor's
budget
and and mr hoffman has not had a chance
to do that
because that we just talked about that
this morning but
do you think you might have that
tomorrow yes we'll have that by tomorrow
so we're showing you what document we're
talking about
yes this is just the one showing
footnotes in the governor's recommended
2223 bucket
thank you and then
if you could go to sections 106 through
of the hb2
we we might actually do more than just
look at these two today as a as a
preview
so sections 106 through 110 were
submitted
by uh the veterans home
um you know as as a
as a if i were a purist
i would be bothered by these sections
because there's a little bit of
internal redundancy where the same thing
is repeated in two of the
sections and that there's some
redundancy also
where one of these sections uh says
something that's already in the
footnotes so it's redundant in that
regard
and so if i were
really fastidious it would be a big deal
to me
to clean up 106 to 110
to get it clean and and lined up
but given all the work that mr ripple is
doing
i i don't know if there's a lot of
benefit
now to do it because it
it has it has no negative effect except
it's
it's unnecessary redundancy and and just
not
clean so um
so i guess what i'm saying is i think i
i would be willing to just accept
sections 106 through 1 and 110
knowing that they're not technically
clean
but that they're not going to do any
harm it's okay
if anyone disagrees with that
you know this is actually a good time to
say something because
it would require mr ripple and uh lba to
do some
or the ols to do some work uh and the
value of that work i think is marginal
um are there any
questions or comments on this
so so let's try it this way i i would i
would entertain
emotion to accept sections 106
through 110 as written in hb2
i would move that are we really just
asking kevin though to produce the
amendment first and then actually vote
on it tomorrow
in this case we're just going to accept
106 through 110
and not ask him to do an amendment
because
second by representative weiler is there
a discussion
so so i i i'll discuss it just one more
time to summarize my thinking
106 through 110 are fine
if with them in hb2
uh it it it gives the veterans home
some flexibility from a technical
writing perspective there's some
redundancy that could be cropped
out of this but that redundancy isn't
going to cause us any problems in the
next biennium
maybe it can be fixed next next time
around
that's my discussion i i i'm predisposed
to
accepting the motion voting for the
motion is there any other discussion
okay mr clerk would you call a roll
representative earth yes representative
weiler votes yes
representative bean yes
representative walner yes
representative nordgren yes
representative
catherine rogers yes
representative edwards yes
mr chairman of the vote 7-0 oh
super thank you um there were
a couple of other sections that i think
we might have been ready to
accept today can can you take us back to
section 30 and 31.
sure
francesca hennessey came in and
explained to us
um that that these are good
uh as is uh
i didn't sense any disagreement with her
while she was briefing it so i think we
could entertain a motion
to accept sections 30 and 31 as written
in hb2
i moved oh representative morgan has a
question
oh does she i don't see it representing
orgrim do you have a question
no she doesn't so you've moved it and
uh represented a while or seconded it um
is there any discussion on sections 30
not seeing any uh mr uh clerk would you
call a rule
representative earth representative
weiler votes yes
representative bean yes
representative yes
representative nordman yes
representative rogers yes representative
edwards
yes so chairman the vote is 7-0
okay thank you so um so we've accepted
those
all right uh and then going back to a
preview for
tomorrow uh last but not least is
sometime during the day
we're hoping to get a ways and means
update
uh and i'm i'm hoping that it means good
things
so uh is there any comment or question
about that
uh representative irf not about that
after you're done with that
okay for uh i don't see any on that
topic so go ahead
uh kevin sent us all
a list of the remaining funds
or items i guess in the governor's
budget that don't that don't use general
funds
so maybe that could be on the agenda for
tomorrow as well just to say okay
oh nice catch beautiful catch
so let's let so
um excellent catch mr ripple would you
pull that up
the document you sent to us this morning
sure explain what
explain what it is or i think since
representative
if you ask for it i think do you want to
explain what it is
sure
just one second
i've never seen that page
we're gonna have to budget a better
faster computer for you mr richard yeah
i think so
well let me try let me try it a
different way just a second here
and then before we hang out for the
attendees in the audience
if if you have any words of wisdom or
something you want to say
and you can keep it a couple of minutes
we'd love to hear from you before we go
so stand by
information for tomorrow please um
i will need to log off by uh two
or maybe a little after two tomorrow so
mary kalise will be
uh with you after two o'clock tomorrow
to fill in for me
good we'll try not to teach treat her
like a substitute teacher
and she'll try not to beat you up too
much too so don't worry
be mutual
so i i think miss rounds to today
i i i'd have to look at my notes more
thoroughly but i think
in about four places on sections we're
anticipating talking about tomorrow four
or five places
we asked you specifically to to go drill
into the numbers a little bit
yes uh okay so so so
help remind me to to have you talk to
all of them
before uh your time runs out with us
sure thank you please please thank you
okay so representative erf what are we
looking at
i just want to ask kevin a little one
question
the spreadsheet looks a little different
than this but i assume it's just the
same numbers looking differently
uh yes yes okay that's fine so
what i asked uh mr rebel to do was to go
as
the other day he went through all of the
accounts
that had only federal funds and we
voted to accept those from the
governor's budget
and going through the budget there are
many other
accounts that do not have general funds
they might be
agency funds only they might be private
funds only they might be revolving funds
only
so i asked them to pick out all the
other accounts
that have no general funds in them so
that we could just consider them for
approval as the government or has
budgeted them
i guess tomorrow
i have not had a chance to go through
the entire list yet but i was planning
to do it
later i think there are 32 of them
aren't there
or some number like that can you go to
the bottom
32. and and when i looked at them
i i didn't see any issues but
i'm the most junior on the committee so
um
uh i i i don't i don't see any issue
or a problem just accepting these
uh for our proposed
hb1 amendment accepting these into the
amendment
do you do you mr or representative erf
do you
because you haven't had a chance to look
at the document you requested would you
like to defer
voting on it no if
does he need to prepare an amendment or
is this the amendment
well i think we're letting him know that
we want this to go into the hb1
amendment
kind of like we did for the federal rule
right
yeah no i'm fine with that if anybody
else is
mr ripple what's the right way to tell
you
that we want this captured in house bill
one amendment
well i think there's no way to do it no
reason to do an amendment because in
this case you're approving accounts that
are already in
house bill one um but as you did with
the federal funds only accounts you
could certainly opt to vote to approve
this just to
just have a record of the committee's
approval
so uh i'd entertain a motion to accept
these 32 line items
into um the division three budget
proposal
so moved for a second
seconded by representative weiler uh mr
roll would you
ever excuse me uh is there any
discussion on this
i don't want to railroad anyone could
could we go back and look at the middle
of them so
like from 24 at the bottom to 12 or
whatever it's going to be
okay so so now you've i think you've
like glanced at all three pages
a little out of sequence but that's what
they are
all right uh representative weiler
um i say the total is 319 million that's
neither general funding or federal funds
that's right there there are some big
ones on here for example the
medicaid enhancement tax revenue that's
budgeted for uncompensated care
up at the top and the equip revenue
that's budgeted for
uh in long-term supports and services
right below that so these aren't all
inconsequential accounts by any means
that makes sense those taxes are big
thank you
yep is there any more discussion
we have a motion on the floor or any
more discussion not seeing any
mr clerk would you take a role the
motion is to
accept these 32 line items into the
division
iii budget proposal representative earth
yes representative weiler votes yes
representative bean
yes
yes representative nordgren
yes representative rogers
yes representative edwards yes
mr chairman the vote is 7-0 okay
thank you very much and um thank you mr
ripple for putting that together and and
representative
for for thinking about it i i like the
fact that we're shrinking
the amount of moving parts
um so uh
i at this point have
uh think that we've accomplished what i
thought we
could accomplish today we have more time
available
but because um tomorrow's going to be a
busy day and i think it's going to take
folks some some some independent time to
read
and and get ready for some of these
things i i'd be
i'd be open to having folks have take a
an independent work afternoon and not be
in work session
representative walner do you have a
question well i am ready with my
amendment if
but i'm willing to wait until tomorrow i
i
i want to do it now because tomorrow is
full if
we're not at lunch time now if you're
ready let's do it
okay great okay so
you probably need to take um
look at your house bill one and go to
page
950 of the governor's budget
mr can you share that just again i'd
like i like making sure we're all
looking at the same thing
or
normally i would uh take a bio break
here
but this feels like it's going to be
done in about 15 minutes
is that your estimate representative
walner or do you think it's going to be
longer
no unless there's a lot of questions i
can do it i think in 15 minutes
easy
okay so if you go if you take a look at
class line 536 which is called
employment related child care
and i think if you remember the other
night at the public hearing
there were a number of people who spoke
to this line
so you can see that between um
20 21 and then with the governor
proposes
is quite a
quite an amount of less funding
and the real concern here from the child
care community is
that um you know during the pandemic
it's been really hard to gauge how many
children would be in child care how many
child care centers would be open
how many child care providers would be
available so it has been
really hard to come up with um
estimates of how much child care is
going to be needed
when we get past this um how quickly
will we go back
to where we were before
um so my suggestion is
instead of adding money funds to the
line
i'm suggesting a way that and we'll show
you the amendment
that i'm suggesting to a house bill too
i'm suggesting a way that
if we start drawing down the 26
million if we start drawing down
rapidly because people are going to go
back to work and i think
that's our goal we want people back to
work we we don't want people to
have to stay home and
it apply for state state services so
we want people to go back to work so as
that draws down
if we get to the point where um in
either
towards the end of 22 or towards the end
of 23
um there would be those lines would be
out of money
and all of a sudden everyone would lose
their reimbursement
or have to go onto a wait list
that we have a way of
monitoring that and then transferring
from the tanf reserve
money into those lines so let's maybe we
could
show the um maybe we could show the
amendment kevin
sure
can you give us a second to read this i
i i just would like to read the words
okay
okay i i've read it is is are other
people
ready to for go ahead represent walnut
continue
okay well um so
the tanf reserve fund there are only
certain
things that you can use the tanf reserve
for
and one of those is child care because
obviously
getting families back to work and not on
tanf
temporary assistance to needy families
is a goal that
the department has but i think it is a
goal shared by
probably most of the people in new
hampshire
that families should be working and
supporting their families so
without child care though if you have a
young family
it's really it's hard it's hard to do
that so
the child care
employment related child care program
helps families low income they're very
low income families
low income families be able to afford
child care it's a
they call it a scholarship program it's
basically a subsidy
parents pay apart and the state state
and federal government pay apart
um so what this does is basically
um safeguards that if we get to
like may and we're out of money
we don't have to say to families okay
no more money no more money for child
care so families
may lose their jobs they may have to
stay home i mean there's
and um i don't think that's what any of
us want to have a child care weightless
and then
families that needed care would have to
go on to wait list so i don't think
that's
what we want um and like i said
the tanf reserve is
pretty specific about what um
what it can be used for and child care
is one of those things that the federal
government
encourages states to use
the tanf the tan of funding for
child care so um
people have questions yeah oh yeah i
just was waiting for you to
finish with your okay so uh we have
representative weiler and then
representative verv
i just want to look and see the
amendment numbers to put it in the
record
plus i think this is brilliant so this
doesn't add
any new money it just is not available
for us thank you very much
no it does not ask for additional funds
it only asks that
if we start to run out and we you know
we may not run out the first year we
don't know
we have no way of predicting really how
many families or how quickly families
are going to go back to work
after having lost their employment or
been at home with their children during
the pandemics so
um i hear from providers that people are
already starting to come back and
they're starting to go back to work
and these i want to remind you that
these are low-wage workers
these are people in jobs that are
hands-on jobs these are not people who
are going to stay home be on a computer
these are people who are nursing
assistants
um aides in nursing homes
working in restaurants these are people
who
are going to really have to go out of
the home and get back to work
representative irf
i think this is an outstanding amendment
the tanf fund was originally budgeted to
be down to i believe like 14 million
dollars by the end of this year
and because there hasn't been a need to
draw it down for the last couple years
it's much higher than that i think it's
up over 40 million dollars
so the tana fund certainly has the
capacity to support what representative
walnut has proposed this is absolutely
outstanding
i appreciate the support thank you
well so representative wallner that
would all be too easy so
so let me let me throw the frog in the
punch bowl
so so i i love the concept i think it's
a great idea
my only issue with it is it reads a
little bit like
we're signing a blank check and and just
i'll draw your attention to two words
that i would
like to have you consider changing um
i'm not i'm not asking you i don't tell
any i'm just asking you to consider
changing them
and line four the word
fully so i would like to just see the
word fully
deleted to where it reads
to to fund employment related child care
services to avoid a wait list
okay okay the word fully
um is is just kind of
adds a level of extremeness that i don't
really know
the upper gauge to that the upper end
we're not trying to be extreme
we're just trying to make sure there is
no wait list right
and and so uh then the other one
is on line five
towards the end of that blind five where
you use the shall
uh i i would i would like to see the
word may
just because i i'm a little less
directive than some people i i would
like the management of dhhs
to have the flexibility knowing what we
want them to do
but you know if for some reason they're
having problems i
i don't want to be compelling to do
something that doesn't make sense
so so i i would i would ask that the
word shall
on line five be changed to may and
that the word fully on four
be deleted do you want to
think about that overnight
i agree with fully i want to think about
xiao
and i will tell you that i've had
conversations with the department about
this amendment
um they're they're very supportive of it
i have um also talked with um karen
rounds about it and she was supportive
of it
and i talked to um the people who
managed the
um the child care program and they
they felt comfortable with it and um
especially as we go into these times
when we don't know what's going to
happen
for children needing to come back to
child care
so let me think about the may and xiao i
understand
i under i certainly understand that and
i will
um
i will um maybe get back to you at the
final tomorrow
or or just call me if if you if you come
to you know think about it because i'm
just giving you my first reaction
also because i have not read the
language until 10 minutes ago so
you're you're getting sort of my first
blush response
so uh ms rounds do you do you have a
comment question yes um
i think it it goes to um
to your comment about um
about it not being a blank check if you
will there are federal
regulations as to how much tanf we can
transfer to cd
ccdf um so we
uh there would be about another six
million dollars over what has already
been budgeted in tanf that we could
transfer to ccdf
um so you know i think a possibility
would be to just add
um to the extent allowed by federal
regulation and that
i mean it wouldn't be a blank check
anyways and we would have to follow the
federal regulation anyway but it it
would just
draw that attention to it's not a blank
check yeah
so so i would be happy that way too if
if the language of this section uh
stated what the what the what the guard
rails were
for um spinning a little tighter
okay i will work with kevin to reward
that okay
that'd be great okay great and i would
just say we are in support of
it it doesn't it works for us
okay so um so we're gonna
what what are we gonna uh we'll call
that the uh the
the the walnut babysitting money or
something no
don't please don't call it babysitting
please
child care employment related child care
i just can't call it a scholarship i i'm
having a trouble with it that's fine
that's fine
you don't have to call it scholarship
right
all right so um okay so we'll talk about
that again tomorrow
uh and uh if you want to work or
work with uh mr ripple to get the
wording right in his rounds
maybe ms rounds you could you could take
the first shot at writing something so
it
comports to federal regulations
i i don't i think just adding um as
allowed by federal regulation is fine i
don't think i need to
kevin got that mr ripple yes i do
all right so so thank you that that was
uh
that was nine minutes oh no that was 14
minutes so that was a good time estimate
on your part
um okay so uh are there
any comments or observations from
our participants i see 26
in the crowd
give you a second to raise your hand and
then for the committee members i'm going
to ask you what i always ask you about
do you have any comments for the good of
the committee comments
feedback thoughts uh why don't you go
now representative nordgren thank you
thank you i was wondering if you could
just
go through our agenda for tomorrow all
through the meeting today we keep
talking about tomorrow
and i think it'd be helpful for us and
the public
to know exactly what our agenda is
from the start of the day at 9 30.
yes ma'am we we've been publishing that
as we've gone
this morning if you take a look at uh
your email from me
you'll see something with the word uh
final sprint schedule or something like
that
where i shared the schedule with you
as of this morning but to your point
it's uh we've added some stuff and moved
some oh
i'm not ready i still have to add
representative walner's uh child
scholarship
tanf money to it so this isn't a
complete schedule
i'll send it to you shortly how's that
that's fine i'm just concerned that the
public might have lost track
they they could have um
i uh the image that i'm gonna send
to the committee i think mr ripple can
post
uh to our website
that would probably be helpful thank you
all right
so let me update it by putting
representative walner's
idea item on it for tomorrow
and then we'll uh i'll send it out
i don't see any hands up in the
attendees
and so uh so at this point
i'm i'm ready to adjourn uh your hand is
still up representing nordgren deep
nope sorry okay
well uh so we're scheduled to start
again at 9 30.
i i think many of us are trying to
prepare for tomorrow
and for this final sprint with an hb1
amendment
so um so you got this afternoon to work
on stuff
thank you